hi Gregory Brothers hi do you guys like
to be referred collectively to as the
Gregory Brothers did you prefer your
human names when we're all in one place
it's just more it's just more efficient
yeah Sarah how do you feel about being a
brother feel um like I've worked hard to
get this title yeah and um you know I'm
proud of it let anybody take it away
from me exactly than the Gregory
Brothers for like five or six years and
maybe like every four years we should
have just done a year of being the
Gregory sisters oh yeah since Sarah's
expected maybe next year we can be the
Gregory mothers just for one year only
if you had to get one word tattooed on
you what word would that be and but
first off do any of you have tattoos I
do not do it do you I think we might be
a zero tattooed group yeah that would
have been amazing if we'd found out
there's one right now I saw like the
emotion go through all of you that
moment of like is this gonna be a reveal
that we don't know yes I'm pretty sure
but what if Andrew has one under his
beard ha ha ha but if you had to get
only one word tattooed on your person
what words do you think you would choose
I would probably just get beats by dr.
dre technomages
if you could throw cold limp spaghetti
in the face of anyone who would you
throw it in the face of like sauceless
cold sticky
spaghetti it doesn't necessarily ruin
their day like it's a surprise it forces
them to be aware something that they're
not doing correctly this is helping me
cuz it's like okay I don't have to think
of someone I hate necessarily just
someone that I like need to shake things
up would be awoken from their stupid
slumber yeah I was thinking maybe um no
please not listening to this but our our
office landlord
oh we rent like this leaves a huge fan
of the podcast cuz even is even tweeting
in and giving me great ratings on iTunes
he's just a lovely guy but he's but he's
the type that like when he gets himself
started talking to you he's not talking
to you anymore just talking at you and
just kind of gets himself going 20
minutes later he's like telling you how
bad New York used to be and that you
couldn't go outside if you weren't
carrying a piece forget about it you're
like why we were just talking about the
utility bill or something and so I feel
like you were like two minutes in that
conversation you knew where was going
like some you know some quick linguine
to the face can really cut this off
pineapples have you checked with your
doctor so there's a lot of different
ways that fruits can be more fun thank
you guys for regaling me with that now
we have some questions from Twitter so
robot behind us I have to tell you oh my
god what's happening there's a rope what
and I hate it
yeah I was what I know who that is I
don't know is this a question from
Twitter yeah this is guys I have these
guys skyping to ask you a question this
is their make-a-wish
what is this Roomba I don't understand
it okay as long as we're all seeing it
together it's not just one thing that
I'm seeing in my own head video Roomba
we surprised you with invasions of your
privacy Gregory Brothers welcome to your
challenge excited so this challenge is a
take on the chicken nugget challenge but
it's called the chicken Succot challenge
hahahaha yeah here's how it works
basically we'll be facing off in a game
of chicken to see who will break first
to a laugh first two of us will face off
at a time and what we will do is take a
little bitty bit of helium into our
person via balloons and then we will say
to the other person looking them square
in the eye the most serious thing you
can think of in your brain and then if
the other person laughs they're out and
then two more people will face off first
that lapses out and those final two
people will face off in the ultimate
chicken Succot challenge and Sarah you
will be a judge for this game because I
don't think it's correct for a pregnant
lady to be sucking helium I don't know
I'm not a doctor I just assumed let's
play big yeah we haven't ever need like
total illnesses on counter yet so I'd
rather not start today
okay so Stephen who are the first two
contestants are I have cards here with
our names on them okay I'll let you guys
choose chu at random Andrew I pick
myself up Evan Evan
okay you two will face off first well
I'm gonna lose this
I have nothing out loud just thinking
about you since your since your feel the
feeling afraid you get to go first okay
I'm will so if I make Andrew laughs on
the first go does he get like eight I
have to have my eyes open is that a rule
yeah yeah maintain eye contact the whole
time with me okay you're adopted
no you are even judged out here just get
it out haha I hope that that's the way
he's telling you to I only say true
things that's like helium does right
yeah
Oh display there was an exhale at the
end that was I think I think you can
count as an Evan laugh I laugh okay so I
go again okay
I'm concerned about the appearance of
your nuts yeah it was an exhale it was a
that's a laugh okay I mean she's the
judge I'm getting scared by the judging
is absurd alright I laughed at graceland
was I ever said we'll have a show the
bumpers and we a stopwatch wait 10
seconds in the Olympics they have to
deal with the audience as well yeah and
did North Korean judges reps I can't
believe the referees in here is this the
line for the puddle of mud secret
showcase
i shouldnít go back markets that suck
heads he's clear Wow anything I've ever
done
yeah how do you not laugh at that ah
okay okay ready
on your mark get set suck I like turtles
Oh as I was Arta making me laugh four
score and seven years ago our
forefathers set forth upon this great
nation to bestow upon the earth
just making the end up Greece you're in
the clear oh yeah because
yes wolf coughs not doctors kids I've
had to deal with them before oh boy
now just imagine the calculation my drag
queen name is georgia o'queef all right
I like big butts and I cannot lie
Wow Wow let's go I deserve it honey mark
get set suck you ever feel insignificant
when you look out into the vast
emptiness of space
you're in the clear go sorry mom I'm
sorry but he's not gonna make it hit him
right in the crease might go into a dark
place is too good and delivering that
line my questing Saturday be doctor sent
that to you
every time I go to the London mouth I
always knew the sec if I always get the
best when I go home cuz I've never had
that sock again okay you're good [ __ ]
this is a very intense and I killed him
I killed them all and it made me feel
good it was good I went home and I
laughed about it and I thought about all
the blood everywhere
and then I had mashed potatoes can Tom
you're actually admitting to a murder
right be the perfect time I can always
be the true it's true theorem then on
that day the best potatoes were not self
- nuh-uh
and it Bush it'll tasted like a pizza
and I couldn't finish it it was the
worst Thanksgiving ever and I had to
take mom home and fella to remake the
mashed potatoes make the mashed potatoes
again I feel like your powers of humor
way off on you
yeah your bodies are built use me mister
have you seen my penis so glad my penis
in your son where ever you see might be
nasai can't find it anywhere can't find
either of my penises Oh can't find any
my penis is feeling pretty lightheaded
- because I don't think anyone can top
and or off penis like a good Allah
forego we'll make sure them against you
guys um some sort of medical attention
and if you thought that was great listen
to the full podcast on iTunes and make
sure you go over to the gregory brothers
channel and subscribe they don't do
anything like this on thank you guys for
participating go get you some cars home
i don't have to walk anyway helium
doctor in the building thanks for
watching kids be safe with helium
probably just don't do it we just did
see you never
the kiss race should be like Kiwis
don't eat the hair and I would then I
would buy it because I would more to
prepare it right now I'm like should I
buy that I don't know if I'm hurt and
then I don't what